parce qu'aussi trop serré dans vos jeans
soit des verts c'est vrai j'ai pas la
loi ça m'amuse beaucoup le remplacer ma
valeur et cyril il remplaça bien sûr
mais j'ai essayé de faire le maximum
non mais il faut travailler le boulot
mais c'est beau match la chanson oui
j'entends bien on fait remettre
vous allez bien en premier métier
j'aimerais et le wydad à tête qui filent
savez comme n 1 victime 50 savais pas
que j'étais ici et je touche personnes
dont moi j'aime bien toucher
allez les amis vous le savez peut-être
pas mais j'étais tient au sort pour
remplacer cyril
[Musique]
le 30 mai isabelle vampires se voir
offrir une chance folle pas dans cette
école pas longtemps mais un problème
autrement plus oui on les appelle là bas
oui bonjour à tous
[Musique]
et le voyage vous deviez pansement mais
non ligue américaine je demande aux
hommes d'église à sa mère isabelle
morini-bosc isabelle fioul
hier vous avez pris les commandes de tpm
paix n'ayant bravo avec prix vous avez
été excellent et côté audience l on est
très bien sorti isabelle
[Musique]